curieusement c'est autour de cette
région doloise que s'articule la
carrière si l'on peut dire de ce
gangster de vocation internationale il
ya dix ans jacques mesrine qui porte
alors allègrement la trentaine et gérant
d'une petite auberge non loin de
compiègne au milieu des bois c'est alors
le début d'une longue série de méfaits
qui le mèneront demain devant les
assises de la scène pour répondre d'une
bonne quinzaine de chefs d'inculpation
du hold up à la prise d'otages et nous y
reviendrons avec l'épisode du tribunal
de compiègne en passant par
l'association de malfaiteurs et la
tentative d'homicide
nous sommes alors en 1973 l'auberge ne
lui suffit plus il part pour l'amérique
enlève un milliardaire s'évadent d'un
pénitencier tu de garde-chasse
il faut ajouter à cela une bonne dizaine
d' attaques de banque pour en arriver à
ce qui nous intéresse c'est à dire
l'évasion de compiègne arrêté au mois de
mars à boulogne billancourt il fait
immédiatement opposition à une
précédente condamnation et demande à
comparaître devant ce tribunal qui a
précisément rendu le verdict mais c'est
là qu'apparaît son caractère disons
diabolique mesrine a envisagé de longue
date qu'il pourrait être arrêté il a
déjà repéré les lieux quand il était
libre et il sait que l'on peut déposer
une arme sur le rebord de la fenêtre
il lui suffira ensuite et ce n'est
certainement pas le plus difficile de
trouver un complice
et c'est ainsi que le 6 juin 73 mesrine
demande à se rendre aux toilettes
un gardien la compagne mais quand il
revient dans son box d'accusés mesrine
cette fois est armé baissez vous tous où
je tue le juge crie-t-il c'est
l'affolement
le gars de refuse de le lâcher mesrine
l'entraînent derrière le président et
braquent le canon d'une arme sur sa
nuque dans sa fuite il va tenter de
tirer sur le substitut sur les gendarmes
ensuite il va tirer précisément puis il
s'enfuit avec le président la voiture
est poursuivi dans les rues de compiègne
il réussira toutefois à s'échapper et
courra jusqu'en septembre 1973
demain pour son procès au palais de
justice de paris
c'est une véritable forteresse que l'on
verra
[Musique]